[Music]
you've seen ryan reynolds quip his way
through three assassin adventures two
heist adventures and one what if ghosts
were also cops adventurer this is a joke
hilarious
now before you see him quip his way
through a time travel adventure see ryan
quip where you've never seen him quit
before
in a video game yeah she's good and i'm
fine too thank you for asking okay fine
in a cool video game
free guy
welcome to free city an online
multiplayer world that's one part gta 5
one part fortnite and that's where the
references stop because the script is
from 2016.
[Music]
inside it's a world full of sentient
npcs trapped in a loop of violence
suffering and sexual exploitation but as
awful as that sounds it's based on an
even worse idea it's essentially a
fishbowl game people aren't playing it
they're they're watching it grow so yeah
tucker made some changes no one's
dropping 60 bucks to play small talk
simulator
it's like my tongue in a baby with a
sunrise okay 30 bucks
lesser actors transform their looks or
personality for a role but when your
people's former sexiest man alive you
just keep doing variations of ryan
reynolds until they stop paying you for
it and guy is one of ryren's more
lovable recent deadpools it's like
losing my virginity but in my mouth
he'll climb the ranks of the free city
leaderboard by role-playing as a killer
cop all to impress the girl of his
dreams millie in the game she's a super
hot ass kicker with attitude but outside
she's still jody comer so same diff then
there's the two programmers mouser and
keys mouser and keys come on did this
guy name him you seem
adjective keys invented a way to put a
real version of his crush in a video
game and we're all just going to pretend
he wasn't planning to [ __ ] it one day
and making life difficult for everyone
is studio boss antoine who's like taika
watiti once all the success and
threesome start going to his head what
you talking about willis say what you
will about free guy but good for these
two they've come a long way since their
last movie together i wanna see it
fine
you're super
experience a film that mixes the biggest
game streamers of today with the gamer
speak of 20 years ago boot the trash ass
noob ban him for life wow you are a
special kind of nude don't crib your
jokes from the trolls in free city
trolls with cameos by jacksepticeye
pokemane ninja uh that one and that guy
and uh pass unless channing tatum i
recognize him but the best surprise of
all is more ryan reynolds stealing the
show is hollywood's most evil creation
yet as they finally found a way for
a-list actors to outsource the steroids
to someone else's body you can put the
protein shake down now chris and hugh
and chris and tom and chris and
in a world dominated by the same handful
of franchises cheer for an original
movie to crush it at the box office and
this brand new story about an extremely
friendly guy who doesn't realize he's in
a fake world designed for our
entertainment full of background jokes
that tip us off something subtly wrong
where he gets fixated on a strange woman
from the real world that he's only seen
once and his best friend is designed to
keep him immersed in the reality and he
starts slowly getting curious to try new
things and we keep cutting away to news
reports and reactions from viewers
around the world and he can only escape
by getting over the uncrossable water
and past the horizon while the
mastermind throws every possible kind of
obstacle in his path yessiree any
similarities to any other films are just
one of those coincidences where two
riders have the exact same idea 25 years
apart oh and in case i don't see you
good afternoon good evening and good
night
don't have a good day have a great day
so whether you're looking for more of
the same or the same of more this movie
sure to have something for you that
almost has something to say about the
game industry you said free city 2 is
backwards compatible i was lying almost
has something to say about class
struggle it's like every npc
went on strike and almost has something
to say about ethics and ai even if i'm
not real this moment is but definitely
has something to say about how people
are dumb little seals who only clap for
the things they already recognize if you
love kentucky fried chicken and i made
kentucky fried chicken and i know that
you love kentucky fried chicken why
would i make another restaurant called i
don't know albuquerque boiled turkey
eyepiece and sequels that is the thing
that people want i know that sounds like
they're making a critique but trust me
it's a confession
oh it's that thing from that other thing
that i like whoa
awesome
starring
emmett
can't get out
thoroughly post-modern millie
keys keys keys keys in for you guys only
people in la are going to get this joke
bro code 21 jump down left right a b
start street hugh hackman
coming soon free city 2 bigger
better
wait who's that epic voice i thought we
had something special ryan and funny
name
ryan reynolds and the terrific heroical
not just good very great day
ryan you're a funny guy but next time
make it a little less obvious that you
helped write the script he's funny and
he's sweet and he's so handsome he's
also a really cute guy and not just the
face you know but like the whole thing
then let me do it for you
guy
you
are
dreamy also he's like crazy hot oh my
god totally i'd hit those pixels hard
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
like a bentha
happy 100th birthday count warlock
good
good
it's all going according to plan
[Laughter]